[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai la grande joie le grand
plaisir le grand honneur de me retrouver
avec un ivelinois il a passé son enfance
à saint-sir l'école tout Pr d'ici il est
maintenant célèbre il s'appelle coach
Joe et son son nom son vrai nom c'est
Joël bourima Joë bourima bonjour bonjour
et merci de me recevoir merci à vous
d'avoir accepté l'invitation vous êtes
de retour sur vos ternatal on n'est pas
loin de sincir l'école voilà et vous
êtes ici parce que vous avez une
actualité assez brûlante et notamment la
sortie d'un livre aux éditions talent
édition qui s'appelle coach Joe toujours
tout donné alors voilà tout un programme
alors dans ce livre en fait il est
structuré d'une façon particulière
c'est-à-dire que vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe euh vous racontez mettons un
chapitre de votre vie après c'est
ponctué par un témoignage de d'une
personne qui a été importante dans votre
entourage et après c'est reponctué par
un conseil très clair très précis ouais
on est d'accord ouais c'est ça voilà
alors pour revenir sur votre carrière
professionnelle vous avez démarré euh
après vous êtes bien accroché comme prof
de sport et apparemment ça a pas été la
le plaisir que vous souhaitez imaginz
c'était pas ouais c'était pas le métier
de rêve que je m'imaginais en fait et je
suis même pas allé en fait jusqu'au
professorat j'ai pas passé mon concours
c'est pendant mon cursus universitaire
au niveau de ma 2e année de fac STAPS
exactement que j'ai fait à ORSA euh que
j'ai eu un stage et durant lequel je me
suis retrouvé face à des élèves et c'est
durant ce stage que je me suis aperçu
que métier dont je rêvais depuis des
années n'était pas forcément celui bah
que je me voyais faire sur sur le le
reste de ma vie et c'est à ce moment-là
que j'ai bifurqué vers un un diplôme
différent et qui m'a amené vers le
coaching par la suite juste par
curiosité qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient ces
élèves il vous bah c'était le je
retrouvais pas en eux le le le le
l'envie de faire du sport que moi
j'avais à leur âge d'accord et et moi ce
ce ce métier de de professeur de PS hm
hm euh j'en rêvais parce que quand
j'étais euh en enfant euh je les
attendais comme un fou mes 2 heures de
sport et euh j'étais content de voir ce
prof qui bah qui essayait de nous
motiver et qui essayait de nous pousser
et euh dans ma tête moi je voulais être
comme ce prof là avec des élèves euh
comme moi réceptif qui veulent pratiquer
et qui sont euh bah qui sont demandeurs
après c'est aussi pardon je couple au
prof de donner comme disait notre ami
Johnny l'envie d'avoir envie aussi ouais
ouais c'est clair mais on s'aperçoit
enfin je me suis aperçu moi
qu'aujourd'hui même avec tous les moyens
euh qu'on avait et qu'on nous donnait
euh il était très difficile en fait de
faire prendre conscience aux élèves ce
que le sport pouvait leur apporter et ça
vient aussi bah de plus haut puisqu'on
on est dans une dans une dans une
société où on dévalorise un peu euh
l'activité physique et sportive bon là
on est en train d' bah là ça revient ça
revient mais là moi je vous parle de ça
il y a 20 ans ok il y a 20 ans euh bah
le sport est devenu une option au bac
euh on a que 2 heures de sport c'est
même pas du sport c'était de l'activité
physique et sportive où on se poussait
pas vraiment on apprenait à connaître
son corps et euh et tout ça bah les
élèves ils étaient pas très
réceptifs je me voyais pas moi faire 20
30 ans de carrière là-dedans euh il y
allait la boule au ventre sûrement pas
c'était pas mon objectif donc j'ai
bifurqué vers vers un autre cursus qui
m'a emmené vers le coaching sportif
d'accord alors voilà on on a le début de
votre vie au début donc vous avez cette
envie de d'être quand même prof de sport
qui est chevillé en vous et au moment de
l'orientation au collège on vous
dit ça va être chaud pour toi ça va être
dur trouve trouve autre chose en sortant
de 3è parce que bah parce que peut-être
aussi je montrais pas assez de capacité
et je je je je n'évoluais pas au niveau
auquel j'étais supposé évoluer j'étais
un élève on va dire moyen mais j'avais
toujours cette cette annotation dans mes
bulletins qui était à des capacités et
toujours peu mieux faire parce que en
fait comme je m'embêtais et que
j'appréciais pas trop l'école je faisais
juste le strict minimum pour avoir la
moyenne et et voilà et sauf que la
moyenne ça suffissait pas en fin de 3è
pour m'envoyer en seconde générale et et
on m'a orienté là vers un cap BP2 donc
bien loin de du cursus que j'espérais
que j'espéis faire voà bon que vous avez
quand même suivi pas le choix sorti 3è
14 15 et à un moment vous dites est-ce
qu'il y aurait pas la une infime chance
pour que je réintègre le cursus général
vous m'arrêtez si je me trom et vous
allez interroger vos profs et ils vous
disent si éventuellement il y a une
petite chance mais bon vas-y tu
arriveras jamais ouis et vous c'est
rentré dans votre tête c'est çaen est
pas
sorti on on va aller la saisir ouais
ouais donc en sortie de capbp que j'ai
très facilement sans j'avais certaines
facilités donc j'ai pas forcément
travaill sur ces de années mais je m'en
sors avec des notes plutôt plutôt plutôt
honorables qui me permettent de
réintégrer un cursus normal justement
vers une première d'adaptation qui me
permettra de passer ensuite un bac et
ensuite d'aller à la fac et alors c'est
pas la facilité que vous choisissez
parce qu'en fait le lycée de près de
chez vous vous refuse et le lycée qui
vous accueille il est à Rambouillet il
est à Rambouillet ouais le bout du monde
vous mettez un temps fou pour y aller
même de Sin enfin je sais pas vous
mettiez longtemps pour y aller ouais moi
j'avais au moins ouais 45 minutes oui
enfin c'est long pu faut faut voilà
encore une fois la motivation et et puis
voilà après tout s'est enchaîné presque
de façon fluide on peut dire ouais
jusqu'au bac puisqueen fait après le bac
j'ai encore des bâtons dans les roues
puisqu'on m'explique que le bac que j'ai
fait qui était un bac à dominante
commerciale ne serait pas suffisant pour
intégrer la fac puisque j'avais pas fait
de de matière scientifique on vous l'a
pas dit avant ça on me l' enfin on me
l'avait dit mais on m'avait expliqué que
pas de souci tu pourras quand même
récupérer une fac avec un il faut juste
un bac c'était ça qu'on m'avait dit il
te faut un bac euh général pour pouvoir
intégrer la fac donc moi je suis allé
vers un bac général celui qui qui qui
qui m'était accessible et en fin de bac
maintenant on m'explique que du fait que
j'ai fait un bac commercial euh ça va
être compliqué parce que il fallait
faire un bac S et avoir des bases en
physique en biologie et cetera parce que
j'allais être amené à faire de la physio
de l'anatomie et cetera et sauf que là
j'ai 18 19 ans donc je suis en âge de
dire non je veux arrêter l'école c'est
un peu conflit avec mes parents mais
j'arrête l'école et je me retrouve donc
à travailler petit boulot à droite à
gauche sur 1 an avant de prendre
moi-même mon dossier et d'aller à la fac
et dire voilà je veux m'inscrire je veux
repartir dans un cursus qui me plaît que
je veux faire et euh vous avez fait
comme pour votre lcé à rembouillé
exactement d'aller vous vendre tout seul
et vous faire accepter là où vous
vouliez donc vous avez été pris j'ai été
pris et donc là bah je fais mon mes 3
ans donc dug universitaire et
une licence licence ouais et euh et que
j'ai du premier coup malgré les les dir
et tout ce qui était dit avant quand on
veut comme quoi en vous sentiez que
c'était c'était pour vous ouais et ce
que j'apprenais c'était quelque chose
que j'appréciais que j'aimais que
j'avais envie d'apprendre difficile ou
pas l'implication n'est pas la même et
forcément le résultat en sortie de ces 3
ans n'est pas le même que en sortie de
trè quoi c'est clair après alors on va
pas raconter toute votre vie mais juste
bon vous avez donc donc vous êtes parti
aussi en Australie faire des petits
boulots parce que vous êtes dit si je
veux voir grand il faut que je parle
anglais couramment vous l'avez fait et
après s'enchaîne un truc incroyable
c'est que vous travaillez dans une salle
de
sport je suis en train de raconter votre
livre ça va ça va c'était quoi cette
salle de sport c'est une salle de sport
parisienne plutôt plutôt up qui
s'appelle l'usine a le monde de en fait
de la télé de la finance de la mode qui
s qui s'y croise d'cord et là-bas je me
fais une cl ientelle plutôt bah
respectable plutôt cool qui me permet
d'évoluer et à ce moment-là moi je pense
que bah ça y est ça va ouais moi ça me
va des plus belles salles parisiennes je
travaille dans le monde du sport je suis
en contact avec des gens et moi la la
relation humaine c'est un peu ce qui
m'importe puisque c'est la base de mon
travail donc jusque là je croyais que
bah tout était bon et que j'allais filer
sur mon rail sauf que en 2009 je
rencontre au Marsy que je prépare pour
le film intouchable et ensuite
intouchable fait ce que ça a fait un des
films les plus vu en France et en dehors
de nos frontières ce qui fait que mon
nom tourne dans le milieu du cinéma
français dans un premier temps puisque
je travaille ensuite avec Gadel my Leila
becti Marina FO que je prépare pour des
films jusqu'en 2000 2012 2013 où là j'ai
un client américain qui me qui me
présente rencontré pardon sur la salle
voilà à l'usine qui me présente Canier
West qui est un artiste américain et qui
ensuite me prend un peu pour voyager à
travers le monde et à partir de là bah
l'aventure internationale commence ouais
voilà et vous le suivez et et et et de
là vous vous êtes dit bah j'ai bien fait
de partir en Australie parce que sinon
j'aurais jamais eu le job et il me
fallait l'anglais pour se pour saisir
cette opportunité VO et après Kenny West
et ben c'est la famille Kardashian ouais
qui vous adopte comme coach et j'ai volu
là-bas encore jusqu'aujourd'hui avec eux
à Los Angeles puisque après après 2 ans
de voyage entre 2013 et 2015 avec
canyier West et la famille Kardashian
bah je j'en viens à la conclusion qu'il
est beaucoup plus simple pour moi de
bouger là-bas avec toute ma famille
puisque eux sont à Paris et d'emménager
d'emménager à Los Angeles et donc j'y
suis depuis 8 ans maintenant d'accord
avec des allers-retours à Parisil faut
dire aussi pour ceux qui ne le sauraient
pas vous êtes aussi le coach sportif de
la starac pour la 2è saison actuellement
ouais sur la Star Academy 2è saison on
est venu vous chercher ouis et on vous a
gardé pour la deè saison ça se passe
bien ça se passe super bien est-ce qu'il
y a des jeunes de cité qui qui font
partie des des élèves
h je pense pas non dans ce que je vois
là j'ai pas creusé moi à leur demander
mais là de ce que je vois je pense pas
d'accord ok alors maintenant ce livre on
va maintenant qu'on a fait le tour de
votre votre carrière quand même
incroyable fait de de rencontres et de
chance que vous avez saisir saisir et
vous avez décidé d'écrire ce livre alors
si jeune on écrit sa bio pourquoi pour
qui bah comme vous le dites si jeune en
j'ai trouvéis presque ça prétentieux en
fait et ce qui fait que dans un premier
temps j'avais dit non parce qu'on vous
l'a proposé on me l'a proposé à la suite
d'un reportage que j'avais fait sur TF1
en fait j'ai des maisons d'édition qui
m'ont contacté et j'avais 37 38 ans à
l'époque et je voyais pas l'intérêt de
faire un livre enfin je pensais que bah
ça allait faire justement prétentieux
orgueilleux qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pour
écrire un livre j'ai pas sauvé la
planète j'ai pas et donc euh vous êtes
sauvé vous-même déjà déjà ce qui est
déjà bien et c'est et c'est un peu après
ce qui m'a ce qui m'a poussé à le faire
puisque j'avais j'ai commencé les
réseaux sociaux quand je suis arrivé aux
États-Unis et via les réseaux sociaux
après avoir vu ce documentaire euh bah
j'ai eu plein de retours plein de
messages de de profils différents des
mamans qui me disaient que elles avaient
vu le reportage et que leur fils voulait
suivre cette voie làà sportive euh que
j'ai eu des des frères et des sœurs euh
qui me disaient que le leur petit frère
avait été B bougeb devant le reportage
et que ça les avait motivé et c'est en
voyant justement ces centaines de
message que je me suis dit bah pourquoi
pas l'écrire finalement ce livre parce
que ça sera peut-être une réponse à tous
ces gens à qui j'ai pas pu répondre via
les réseaux sociaux je crois que vous
avez plus de 80000 followers sur
Instagram ouais 100000 quiment mainten
oui j'imagine depuis le covid vous av
vous avez euh été très très actif
pendant le covid et après enfin ça
commençait déjà avant mais ça n'a fait
que queaugmenté ou voilà pouroi en fait
voilà c'est parce que vous dites cette
histoire elle pe elle peut servir moi je
trouve que ça donne un espoir fou et et
puis vous donner des clés bien concrètes
parce que c'est pas tout de rêver de
machin enfin comme vous dites il faut
tout donner
déjà comment tout donner alors parce que
tout donner comme ça tout va ça sera
peut-être pas effectif sur la fin mais
ouais le livre en fait la manière dont
je l'ai construit comme vous le disiez
au début c'était vraiment essayer de
faire comprendre que on y arrive pas
tout seul déjà le le le le truc de je me
suis fait tout seul euh j'y crois pas
trop et montrer justement que les gens
que j'ai pu rencontrer sont pas
forcément des gens que j'aurais
rencontré que je si j'avais si j'étais
resté au quartier en fait donc ça pousse
aussi à bouger sortir de son quartier et
et ouvrir les yeux parce que bah parce
queon passe à côté de beaucoup de choses
en en restant dans cette bulle après
vous dites il faut écouter savoir
intérri
aussi ou c'est pas toujours évident non
plus savoir l'écouter sans être pollué
par les les avis des gens vous dites
n'écoutez pas les n'écoutez pas les gens
écoutezvous vous vous parce que vous
êtes la première et la enfin la première
personne et la seule personne
concrètement à savoir ce que vous voulez
et et à et et vous êtes la seule aussi à
à pouvoir jauger l'envie que vous avez
et ça et ça des fois les personne autour
elle elle parasite cette envie en fait
en en envoyant des des conseils ou des
des des des des du négatif ça vous bah
ça vous touche vous au plus profond et
ça fait diminuer cette envie et au bout
d'un moment on peut même éteindre cette
flamme et et au final vous restez là où
on vous dit de rester quoi voilà vous
oubliez vous oubliez votre votre essence
même et et vous écoutez des voix qui qui
sont pas qui sont pas les bonnes général
ça marche pas voilà ok et vous dites
aussi faut pas se poser en victime c'est
pas parce qu'on habite une cité dans un
quartier défavorisé qu'on est une
victime si faut pas dire on me donne
rien faut aller chercher les chos parce
que ouais ça c'est un peu aussi la
facilité quand rien ne se passe pour
vous de dire que on me donne à rien et
parce que je suis ici on ne me regarde
pas ou on ne me ok d'accord ça c'est
c'est c'est un fait maintenant ça tu le
sais tu le prends et tu fais avec parce
que si on reste sur ces bases là bah
encore une fois il se passera rien Ouen
voilà alors vous vous êtes resté proche
de vos de vos copains de de d'enfance
vous êtes suivi il y en a qui ont réussi
qui ont des belles vies d'autres moins
et et les jeunes actuels de de la cité
euh saint-ire la la cité marron quel
joli nom ouais vous êes all les voir bah
j'y suis toujours hein il oua ouais j'y
passe toujours dès que je reviens je
suis euh je suis dans le coin et on vot
vos parents euh sont toujours sont
toujours là-bas oua is vot maman
Bernadette qui dit fèrement il s'est
fait tout seul est chierre de vous ou
ouais parce qu'elle elle l'a vu elle l'a
vu mais enfin elle a vu la manière dont
je suis monté mais elle avait pas
forcément vu euh tout toutes les
rencontres et tout euh oui mais comme
elle dit elle a fait on fait confiance
quand on est pas quand on sait pas on
fait confiance au prof oua mais ça c'est
c'est un peu aussi le le ouais le le le
le problème moi mes parents ils ont pas
fait spécialement d'études donc devant
les profs exactement devant les profs
c'est bah c'est le prof qui
gagne il y a un moment où et ça ça a été
un gros plus pour moi où où elle m'a
fait confiance à moi quand je lui ai dit
voilà ce que je veux faire et et elle
m'a laissé elle m'a laissé évoluer sans
sans me retenir quoi et ça ça a été
unelle CR en vous quoi en fait c'est ça
et et tout au long de votre parcours
vous rencontrez des gens qui croient en
vous ouis exactement et c'est pour ça
que je voulais les mettre en lumière
voilà George je me suviens plus du nom
ad George adonï qui était un de mes
animateurs et avec qui j'ai travaillé
par la suite vous a fait confiance qui
quoi et qui lui a vu en moi aussi des
des choses que les profs ne voyaient pas
spécialement et que vous vous nosiez
peut-être pas non plus croire ouais
enfin moi je sais même pas que j'y
croyais je savais même pas que ça
existait en fait c'est que on me
laissait même pas entrevoir c'est ses
possibilités et lui on me me tend dans
ce livre euh qui était en fait un un
livre à qui euh qui qui qui préparé à la
à au concours de brevet du brevet d'état
d'éducateur sportifs en même temps dans
ce livre- làà en fait il il me disait
voilà dans le sport regarde un peu lis
tu vas voir il y a des trucs qui te
ressemblent et qui vont qui vont
sûrement te plaire et pourquoi pas bah
évoluer par la suite dans ce milieu-là
et c'est en lisant ce livre- làà que
après bah de fil en aiguille j'en suis
arrivé à ce que j'ai pu faire les clés
après ça vaut pas ça vaut pour tout hein
c'est pas que pour quelqu'un qui veut
réussir notre sport c'est franchement
pour trouver sa voix et et s'épanouir et
en général comme ça qu'on qu'on réussit
alors vous vous avez une méthode
particulière de coaching alors où est-ce
que je l'ai écrit bon vous allez
peut-être me la décrire votre méthode fa
c'est méthode particulière c'est c'est
juste que moi au lieu de mettre la
séance au cœur de mon travail le sport
au cœur de mon travail je mets l'humain
je mets la personne c'est-à-dire que
plutôt que venir et d'imposer mes
séances à à une personne quelle qu'elle
soit j'essaie de connaître la personne
de rentrer un peu là-dedans comment vous
faites et ben par des questions par une
séance bilan et vous avez un
questionnaire je Jae grâce à la PNL en
fait c'est ce qu'on appelle la
programmation
neurolinguistique c'est c'est un outil
que que j'applique à mes séances et qui
me permet très rapidement de jauger
psychologiquement la personne que j'ai
en face de moi et par rapport à ce
profil en fait j'adapte ma séance sont
les profils par exemple que vous ben on
enfin il va y avoir les personnes qui
vont être plus tactiles les personnes
qui vont être réceptifs aux explications
les personnes qui sont là juste pour se
donner à fond et si je fais une séance
euh tactile où je replace beaucoup à une
personne qui aime pas qu'on rentre dans
son espace et ben là j'ai loupé si je
donne des grandes explications à
quelqu'un qui veut juste venir se donner
et brûler ses calories je vais pas être
dans le dans dans dans le bon et et
forcément j'aurais peut-être pas le bon
retour aussi et euh on va peut-être pas
créer la bonne relation qui me permettra
par la suite de bah de lui faire
atteindre ses
objectifs et pour moi bah pour moi ça
sera ça sera un échec donc vraiment
cette première séance bilan au cours de
laquelle je mets en place ce profil m
beaucoup après à à créer ce déclic
psychologique et le la partie physique
arrive ensuite beaucoup plus facilement
et beaucoup plus simplement d'accord ok
et vous continuez à coacher des anonymes
oui bien sûr oui ou oui mais à Los
Angeles à Los Angeles et là je suis là
là je suis à Paris 3 mois moi pour la
Star Academy et donc j'ai repris
quelques personnes ouais c'est elles
sont ch elles sont elles sont cherres
non c'est plus par rapport au temps que
j'ai je sais j'essaie de de de de de
faire au mieux mais mais je revois
quelques personnes anonym et je continue
c'est la base de mon travail ouais ouais
vous avez comment dire des des projets
pour pour après ou bah là je vais
prendre justement le livre comme support
pour aller pour aller échanger pour
aller partager au niveau des des écoles
de de de de l' prè pendant que vous êtes
en France pendant que je suis là là
ouais ououis génial vous allez aller
voir des rencontrer des j'ai commencé
déjà ouais des sentes sociaux des MJC
des lycées des collèges pour pour parler
et leur montrer un peu moi mon parcours
et leur dire bah voilà si vous à un
moment donné là dans votre cursus vous
avez des galères et vous êtes un peu
dans dans le down bah sachez que moi
aussi à un moment je l'ai été mais voilà
ce que j'ai fait et voilà comment ça
s'est passé pour moi et voilà où je suis
aujourd'hui et vous me disiez que il
allait être offert à des lycéens ouais
là il y a une école un centre de
formation qui s'appelle horlomme sur
Paris 11 qui en a pris 2500 et donc tous
les élèves de de ce centre de formation
ont eu le livre à la rentrée et je dois
y intervenir dans leurs trois campus là
sur sur ma période en Franceont lu ouais
ouais ouais bon ben écoutez coach Joe
Joel Bouraya un grand merci merci d'être
venu parce que votre temps est précieux
que vous retournez à l' starac à très
vite cet après-midi même et merci pour
cette belle histoire qui donne vraiment
l'espoir et et ceux qui ne l'auront pas
eu au lycée il faut
l'offrir on a autour de nous parce que
ça ne peut que aider voilà merci c'était
extra à bientôt j'espère on sait jamais
vous allez monter une école un truc on
va voir on va voir par la suite ouais
ouais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas former
des coachs et essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il soit dans la même dynamique que
moi et en France en France ouais si je
le fais ça sera en France bon on se
reverra alors on se reverra on se RRA
merci Joë à très bientôt merci de nous
avoir suivi à très
vite